[Aplausos]
[Música]
durante las próximas décadas el mundo
que todos nosotros conocemos va a
cambiar muchísimo y como siempre eso va
a suponer muchas oportunidades pero
también muchos retos precisamente la
mayor parte de los países desarrollados
se enfrentan a una amenaza tan grande
que es muy posible que su respuesta
determine en términos económicos
políticos y sociales qué países tienen
éxito y qué países fracasan amigos estoy
hablando de la inversión de la pirámide
demográfica del envejecimiento de la
población
sí lo sé estoy seguro de que esto no es
nada nuevo estoy seguro de que la
mayoría de vosotros ya habéis oído
hablar un montón de veces de este tema
sin embargo espera hace un momento os
habéis parado a pensar en las
consecuencias que puede tener este
proceso están vuestros gobiernos
haciendo algo al respecto habéis pensado
vosotros mismos en algo así como un plan
de contingencia personal para poder
enfrentarnos a los riesgos que se
avecinan atentos
el mundo ante una nueva etapa
en poco más de 100 años nuestro mundo ha
cambiado una barbaridad ha cambiado
tanto que si pudiéramos [ __ ] una
máquina del tiempo montarnos por ejemplo
en el delorean de doc y trasladarnos dos
o tres siglos atrás para pasar una
temporada probablemente al poco tiempo
la mayor parte de nosotros sino todos
experimentaríamos un sentimiento muy
fuerte estaríamos como locos por
regresar a casa estaríamos en falta un
montón de cosas nos horroriza haríamos
con el día a día nos veríamos obligados
a trabajar a destajo para poder
sobrevivir tendríamos miedo de ponernos
enfermos e incluso de no poder comer
etcétera etcétera pero no nos desviemos
[Música]
el caso es que a finales del siglo 19 la
población mundial consiguió superar la
barrera de los 1500 millones de personas
pero tan solo en los siguientes 100 años
durante el siglo 20 la población mundial
se multiplicó por 4 hasta superar los 6
mil millones de personas
[Música]
y claro teniendo en cuenta la enorme
velocidad con la que crecía la población
mundial no nos puede resultar extraño
que muchísimos expertos comenzaron a
preocuparse seriamente por la
superpoblación y no penséis que esto era
cosa de expertos científicos o políticos
de tres al cuarto para nada
en
1974 un informe del mismísimo secretario
de estado henry kissinger instaba al
gobierno de richard nixon a considerar
de máxima prioridad el control de la
natalidad en países como brasil india
méxico colombia etiopía o tailandia
según dicho informe la explosión
demográfica que estaba teniendo lugar
suponía una grave amenaza para la propia
seguridad de los eeuu
[Música]
tantas personas consumiendo recursos que
el bueno de kissinger pensaba que nos
dirigíamos a algo así como un mundo de
escasez y de encarnizadas luchas por los
recursos sabéis dando cuenta es
sorprendente como los argumentos mal tus
ya nos se repiten una y otra vez a pesar
de que nunca aciertan
[Música]
el caso amigos es que mientras tipos
como kissinger trataban de pensar cómo
controlar a la población mundial e
influenciar y condicionar sus decisiones
se estaba produciendo ya un cambio tan
grande que supondría un punto y aparte
en todo este debate
[Música]
en los últimos 50 años la tasa de
fecundidad mundial se ha reducido a la
mitad de tal forma que hoy los gobiernos
occidentales ya no piensan en la
superpoblación sino en el envejecimiento
hoy los países europeos e incluso eeuu
tienden a perder habitantes entre su
población nativa fijaos
en alemania por ejemplo desde
1972 han fallecido 5 millones de
personas más de las que han nacido
aunque el caso más extremo de todos ha
sido el de rusia en apenas 20 años entre
1991 y 2011 fallecieron 13 13 millones
de personas más de las que nacieron de
cara al futuro las proyecciones muestran
que en los próximos 50 años la población
nativa en europa se reducirá en cerca de
100 millones de personas
[Música]
y no sólo eso el otro efecto de todo
este proceso es que la población mundial
especialmente la de los países más
desarrollados está envejeciendo a toda
velocidad y eso amigos es algo que
plantea muchos pero que muchos retos
pensiones gastos sanitarios dependencia
y la pregunta es como dirían 3 podremos
financiar todo ese gigantesco gasto para
que os hagáis una idea de lo que estamos
hablando se calcula que en muchos países
europeos en torno al año 2050 el
porcentaje de población con más de 65
años puede situarse en torno al 40 por
ciento y uno de los países más afectados
es precisamente españa atentos
un país de jubilados
[Música]
amigos hagamos un ejercicio supongamos
que la fecundidad en españa y en la
unión europea se mantuviera
indefinidamente los valores que ha
tenido desde el año 2000 y que además no
llegarán inmigrantes queréis saber qué
ocurriría pues atentos al siguiente
gráfico
[Música]
la población entre 18 y 40 años que es
la población que más trabaja y la
población que tiene hijos se pegaría a
un castañazo brutal por supuesto el
número de habitantes con apenas alguna
década de retraso seguiría la misma
tendencia
y es que amigos españa es uno de los
países que más está comenzando a sufrir
la crisis demográfica la crisis
demográfica se agudiza y españa sufre en
2017 su mayor pérdida de población si
echamos un vistazo al promedio de hijos
por mujer podemos entender perfectamente
qué está ocurriendo
[Música]
y eso que la llegada de inmigrantes en
los últimos 20 años ha impulsado la
natalidad hoy el 23 por ciento de los
niños nacidos en españa casi uno de cada
cuatro tiene una madre extranjera
[Música]
pero tal vez el dato más importante para
poder predecir qué va a ocurrir es echar
un vistazo a cómo puede evolucionar que
el número de personas en edad de
trabajar que al fin y al cabo son
quienes generan la inmensa mayor parte
de los recursos públicos y privados pues
bien si suponemos que no existe
inmigración en apenas 30 años la
población española en edad de trabajar
se reduciría en 10 millones de personas
y además según las proyecciones del
instituto de estadística de españa los
españoles nos enfrentaríamos en 2050 a
este panorama
[Música]
9 millones de personas en edad de
trabajar que por supuesto no todos
trabajarían y casi 22 millones de
personas entre niños y jubilados es
decir la población dependiente sería
bastante mayor que la población en edad
de trabajar
[Música]
hablamos de españa pero el escenario de
muchos en la mayoría de los países
desarrollados es muy pero que muy
similar y eso como os podéis imaginar es
algo que tiene consecuencias
[Música]
las consecuencias
amigos hay que ser claros se habla mucho
de los riesgos de la robotización pero
tal vez el riesgo inminente más
importante que las economías
desarrolladas tienen sobre la mesa es
enfrentarse a un proceso de
envejecimiento tan rápido
al fin y al cabo es evidente que una
población tan envejecida tiene muchas
consecuencias por un lado es previsible
que de no cambiar nada el gasto público
se dispare para poder pagar las
pensiones y el gasto sanitario el gasto
para asistir y atender a los más mayores
etcétera etcétera
el gasto en pensiones crece en españa'
un 50% en 10 años y no lo dudéis los
políticos lo van a tener muy claro la
hegemonía de los votantes jubilados va a
ser apabullante es una cuestión de votos
pero al mismo tiempo tal y como hemos
visto va a haber muchas menos personas
en edad de trabajar con lo que la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es cómo
diantres se va a pagar todo este inmenso
gasto se van a subir aún más los ya
altísimos impuestos y a dañar aún más la
competitividad de países con tantos
problemas económicos como españa pues
amigos esa receta nunca funciona ahora
bien llegados a este punto creo que nos
falta contestar precisamente a una
pregunta obligatoria qué diantres se
puede hacer
necesitamos un plan
[Música]
lo sé a los políticos no les suele
gustar nada pero que nada pensar en el
futuro particularmente en los problemas
que tengo que ocuparme y arriesgarán a
perder votos con los problemas de aquí a
20 años no no no no que se encargue otro
pues lo cierto es que si no queremos
encontrarnos con titulares como este que
vais a ver los países desarrollados van
a necesitar un plan el ministro de
finanzas japonés pide a los ancianos que
se den prisa en morir amigos del momento
para tomar decisiones existe y los
países que decidan mirar para otro lado
y no hacer nada se van a enfrentar a
muchos pero que muchos problemas en el
futuro
veréis últimamente aquí en visual
política hemos hablado bastante de
inmigración pues bien la experiencia nos
dice que esta es una buena forma de
frenar el envejecimiento de la población
y ganar tiempo para hacer reformas
como han demostrado australia hong kong
nueva zelanda y singapur la inmigración
puede suavizar el golpe del
envejecimiento rápido
chan john reed director del departamento
de asia y pacifico del fondo monetario
internacional si a pesar del discurso de
muchos políticos lo cierto es que los
países desarrollados van a necesitar que
lleguen muchas personas del extranjero
así que amigos en vez de estar pensando
en levantar muros y cerrar fronteras
sería mucho más aconsejable poner en
marcha un sistema que consiga atraer a
muchas personas de fuera de forma
ordenada y facilitando su integración
claro que aquí no termina todo
cómo es posible casi seguro que los
sistemas de pensiones públicos se van a
volver mucho menos generosos porque no
va a haber presupuesto los gobiernos
deberían también estar impulsando el
ahorro tanto de los propios gobiernos
como de las familias
algún partido político español está
alertando a los ciudadanos del
inexorable tijeretazo en sus pensiones
no todos ellos guardan silencio sobre
nuestro auténtico futuro trasladando la
falsa impresión de que no es necesario
ahorrar para garantizarse un retiro
medianamente digno juan ramón rallo
economista y director del instituto juan
de mariana y junto a todo ello por
supuesto políticas que logran atraer
empresas que impulsen el emprendimiento
y sobre todo que favorezcan la
productividad la inversión en máquinas y
tecnología y en investigación y
desarrollo sí creo que los robots nos
van a venir muy pero que muy bien con
todo este problema
[Música]
desgraciadamente amigos en muchos de los
países afectados entre ellos desde luego
españa no se está haciendo nada de esto
y un momento antes de terminar me
gustaría hacer una reflexión
todo este efecto de envejecimiento que
hemos visto viene acompañado por un
efecto longevidad gracias a los avances
médicos a una mejor alimentación y a una
mayor calidad de vida las tasas de
mortalidad para todas las edades se han
reducido es decir la gente es más joven
por más tiempo
fijaos en los eeuu por ejemplo una
persona de 75 años tiene hoy la misma
tasa de mortalidad que una de 65 en la
década de los 50 en japón los 80 son los
nuevos 65
y además gracias a los avances médicos y
tecnológicos esta evolución no deja de
crecer y crecer lo cual es fantástico
por tanto si las personas tienen ahora
una vida más larga y más productiva no
sería sensato impulsar que continúen
trabajando más años aunque sea de forma
parcial o en tareas más cómodas ahí lo
dejo en cualquier caso para todos los
que estáis viendo este vídeo desde
españa creo que confiar lo que se dice
confiar en nuestros políticos no es la
mejor idea así que viendo el panorama me
parece que no estaría de más que cada
uno de nosotros vaya preparando su
propio plan de contingencia pero ahora
turno para ti sería es partidario de
aumentar la edad de jubilación en tu
país déjame la respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
ya sabes no olvides darle al like y
suscribirte a visual politics si aún no
lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]